deux invités mégane bédard doctorante à
sémiologie l'université du québec à
montréal à l'observatoire sur la culture
populaire contemporaine et simon la
période doctorant en études
cinématographiques à nous la semaine ont
elles aussi bonsoir vous êtes allé voir
le film cet après-midi tous les deux on
ferme la charge
vous sortez de là sial ébranlé
bouleversé inquiète intéressé dessus
déçu et beaucoup de questions aussi
parce qu'on veut la faire des critiques
de cinéma en tout cas 24%
il ya des critiques de ce film qui a été
primé à venise qui pourraient l'être
encore aux oscars inquiétudes quelles
pistes de réflexion pour vous mais en
fait c'est sa fille qui fait beaucoup de
bruit donc on a tant parlé de beaucoup
depuis sa projection à venise est permis
avec qui en fait les les conférences de
presse qui sont sortis on pose la
question est ce que le film suscitera de
la violence est ce qu'il ya un discours
qui sut de la violence en se passe après
avoir visionné le film simon et moi on
s'est posé la question quel discours le
film porte et quelle violence elle
pourrait susciter le joker en soi est un
personnage très violent oui on s'entend
historique de violence mais maintenant
on l'anc dans ainsi qu un discours sur
la lutte des classes donc sur les
situations de pauvreté
on se procure un film oui exactement
dans le
le joe cole dans cette dans cette
version longue c'est il en a plusieurs
il provient d'un milieu haut c'est
quelqu'un qui souffre de maladie mentale
et n'ayons pas les traitements
nécessaires parce que le système n'est
pas capable de lui de l'est procurée
boys band seulement devenir le criminel
qu'on connaît et ça fait en sorte qu'on
absent un film qui est un peu contre la
pauvreté qui qui qui capitalise sur lit
de la part de la masse justement qui
éventuellement les classes l'éclat la
classe ouvrière va tenter de s'en
prendre à la classe à la classe on sait
justement et c'est assez curieux
actuellement surtout dans les climats de
tension qu'on a en pleine campagne
électorale
est ce que c'est un film qui dénonce les
inégalités sociales la tactique qui
propose un discours sur les inégalités
sociales il ya tout un pan du film qui
adresse cette question là mais en tant
que la réponse qu'il nous offre est très
ambiguë par exemple n'est pas vraiment
de position de pauvres ou deux contres
donc c'est très difficile de voir c'est
quoi le discours tant que chez celles
qui posent des questions puisqu'il dans
des rapports aux états unis on
s'inquiète parce que eu un attentat à
aurora le tueur était
déguisé en qualité démenti il était par
exemple des informations qui se sont
comptées un peu se sont modifiées
lorsque la à la manchette est sorti
parce que les inquiétudes sont fondées
c'est moi je ne crois pas qu neuf peut
subitement réveillé une violence en
quelqu'un c'était ça stephen king qui
avait déjà reçu ce type d'accusation lui
qui avait dit que les criminels qui
s'inspirait supposément son oeuvre est
pas besoin de serment au final pour
commettre les actes de ray comme il en
conseil est inutilement aux états unis
mais c'est qu'on devrait pas s'inquiéter
dans ce film on devrait peut-être
s'inquiéter de ce qui le regarde qui de
l'avis de ce nom et si c'est quand c'est
moins le l'oeuvre de fiction dont on
devrait s'inquiéter que les discours qui
sont déjà ancrée dans la société puis
les en fait les commentaires les
inquiétudes compte par rapport à cette
violence le ce n'est pas nous savons par
rapport à un film mais c'est de savoir
si ce film ne déclencherait des actes
qui sont déjà latent donc est-ce que
c'est légitime parce que j'ai pas vu le
film et luigi je ne le verrai pas non
plus est-ce que c'est légitimise
banalise une certaine violence ou port
la souche rapporte à dire que non
sincèrement j'ai pas l'impression que le
le film tant de de faire du dr guy roux
et au contraire ce sunnite très mal pour
lui sans trop donner de détails
donc j'ai pas eu l'impression qu'ils
valorisation de la violence en tant que
dans le temps du fait aussi aucunement
de glorification de servir à cela
donc elle est plus présenté comme un
symptôme d'une révolte des classes plus
pauvres en parler c'est vite donc il ya
ce qui est plus mis de l'avant donc
c'est pour ça que la réflexion derrière
le film est comme très intéressante et
le disco qui se situe en ce moment qu'on
a vu dans le film et c'est bien de se
poser ces questions là justement est ce
qu est ce qu un film peut provoquer la
violence quelle violence est ce que on
s'inquiète parce que ces discours à
exister jeu donc je comprends que ce
n'est pas le film qui provoquerait de la
violence mais ces situations là dans une
société inégalitaire peuvent amener des
gens vulnérables à passer geslin quand
on voit la façon qu'on voit ça
régulièrement aux états unis pour toutes
sortes de raisons et parfois
inexplicable non oui c'est ça c'est le
film je pense que le film suscite de
l'inquiétude parce que surgit
actuellement dans un climat qui est très
très très tendue par exemple en des
éléments du film qui nous a frappés
c'est la facilité avec laquelle le joker
se fait littéralement offrir une arme à
feu
donc là ça soulève le débat justement
sur qui peut mettre la main sur des
révolvers sur des carabines et commettre
les actes
seulement il fallait que je pense que
puis je m'arrête mai
arrêté parce que les critiques de films
hier jeudi a été primé sur le pot place
les moto graphique on dit que c'est un
grand film la plupart des critiques en
font l'éloge à j'ai trouvé sur ce point
là je ne comprends pas d'enthousiasmé
autour de joker je trouve que c'est un
film qui finalement très convenue qui
plagie taxi driver de façon assez outre
outrancière on vante la performance de
joaquin phoenix comme étant d'un gros
score je trouvais très cas battait alors
que c'est un acteur que j'ai prises dont
j'apprécie beaucoup les fossés
hollywoodien comme fille on dirait qu'il
s'agira t-il non parce que oui et non
dans la mesure où c'est un film qui sait
pas quelle casquette portée donc ça sent
le féminicide white un film d'auteur ci
doit être un film de super-héros
silhouette un drame social dont ils
alternent constamment ses trois pôles
aussi très confuse et vous êtes d'accord
avec ça mais je suis d'accord avec ça
donc c'est un peu confus au sens où on
essaie de faire justement une critique
sociale avec un filtre si on veut un
masque de celui populaire personnage du
joker pied de la franchise de banane
qu'on connaît très bien donc on dirait
que la distinguée d'ailleurs dès
maintenant j'ai que oui dans la mesure
où on d'abord ce n'est pas une suite à
aucun film de bahman de voir ça se passe
avant et le film se veut autonome donc
ce niveau ou vera et en joker 2 par
exemple
et aussi parce que généralement au
cinéma le joker ses origines sont assez
floues on ne sait pas d'où il vient
alors là on a vraiment sa jeunesse son
récit d'origine à qui françois qu' on
aurait une explication à allah ou mal
qu'ils habitent ne s'éteint pas un film
à voir avec pour des adolescents oh non
non c'est un film très sont très violent
très difficile peut décemment dans la
violence graphique mais vraiment la
violence le qui a prétendu dans le
certains miroir d'associer d'amérique
nuit oui définitivement
parce que c'est peut-être récemment un
miroir mais c'est quelque chose c'est
une réponse à cette tension là qu'on
ressent très bien en ce moment donc
celle qui la violence latente est propre
à la société américaine celle des armes
à feu et bien alors merci d'avoir avec
nous mais galerie d'art ils sont la
perrière d'avoir vu ce film pour d'où
cet après-midi de venir à réfléchir sur
son impact médecine bucco